[Music]
Rainbow six siege is a house of cards
intricate impressive and incredibly
fragile it's deeply strategic
deliberately paced approach to online
multiplayer opens the door to a world of
thoughtful shooter gameplay - often
overshadowed by the mindless running
Gunnar's of the world but it also hinges
on a number of circumstances that won't
always be within your control
if you're playing with friends who are
familiar with the game and everyone has
a head set and everyone's internet
connection is rock-solid seizures
intensity and tactical depth shine
through but as soon as you remove even
one of those conditions everything
starts to topple and the more you remove
the faster it falls apart that's why I
can't fully evaluate the siege
experience until it's out in the wild
will the community communicate or will
players simply ignore team tactics will
matchmaking operate fairly and
efficiently will the progression system
keep players invested without
handicapping newcomers or otherwise
disrupting the experience these are
crucial questions that I can't answer
until I've had an opportunity to fully
explore the live retail version of siege
that hit store shelves on December 1st
directly below you men on the on the
stairwell below you a juster innate nice
on the other side of the hallway from
you fortunately I was able to sit down
with a final build of the game in a
controlled setting last week to test
every available facet as best I could
those seizure wasn't secretly hiding a
single-player campaign this whole time
it does offer ten solo training
situations that emphasize real-world
inspired counter-terrorist tactics while
introducing the game's myriad mechanics
you'll also find the quintessential
Rainbow six terrorist hunt a cooperative
mode that presents up to four players
with a highly fortified and highly
destructible environment a set number of
AI control terrorists and possibly even
a bomb to disarm or a hostages to rescue
but the real draw here and the star of
seizures seemingly endless betas is the
five-on-five attack and defend online
multiplayer there are no response and no
regenerating health but each round
starts with a brief window for planning
defenders can lock down their position
with a variety of gadgets while
attackers can scout the area with
remote-controlled drones
once that phase ends the tension starts
to mount as attackers coordinate and
defenders grip their guns in anticipate
I have plenty to say about my experience
but first a caveat PvP will be locked
until you reach a certain experience
level in the game which will force you
to play these single-player situations
and probably a good deal of terrorists
on before you're even allowed to access
the competitive multiplayer component
judging by the four or so hours it took
me to beat every situation you'll need
to invest a solid chunk of time and
deceit before you can unlock PvP but I
can't confirm how long it'll take until
I've had a chance to play the full
retail release once I've had a chance to
level my way through the progression
system test the game servers engage the
communities approach the experience
you'll see game spots for review stay
tuned
punched here initiate extraction
has been dropped secure the hostage time
expired
you